and there will be no cutaways okay
we are on screen
from start to finish look who's visiting
i knew it was you josie and the
pussycats reunited oh my gosh ashley
it's so good to see you i've missed you
like crazy take me back to the moment
that you walked back onto the set of
pops again for the first time in quite a
few years what was that like for you and
what was it like seeing the cast again
going back to the set on pops it
actually was a little emotional
especially you know the the scene where
i'm
starting my journey back to and through
riverdale i suppose even just standing
inside
pops while they're you know getting the
shot set up and i'm looking at all the
pictures on the walls and seeing what's
new what's been added what was there
from day one it was surreal i guess and
then seeing everyone was really nice you
know i never get to see anybody they've
been up there for a long time
so it was really nice to be able to
reconnect and enjoy vancouver in a way
that i hadn't when i was living there we
were gonna help you and the gang save
riverdale when roberto first approached
you and said i want josie to come back
for this special josie and the pussycats
reunion episode of riverdale what was
your initial reaction you know i mean
i've been playing her for a while now
and
when roberto approached me with this
episode idea it was to give josie a
chance to come full circle for her to be
a fully realized household name
superstar that we know her to be in the
comics but we hadn't gotten a chance to
see on screen so it was an homage to
that
and also a chance to kind of bring a
little bit of the katy keene josie that
we got to see for just a moment and you
see those elements by some of the cast
that's in this upcoming episode and that
was really nice that was the main reason
why i wanted to do it was to
give josie her
justice i guess okay just as a reminder
this is josie and the pussycats
these are my songs now when we start
writing new material trust me you both
will be a part of the creative process i
wanted to have a sense of agency quite
frankly i just really wanted to feel
like it was gonna be worth not just our
time as creators but it would be worth
the viewers time to see something
different that they hadn't seen and had
been asking for for so long i really
wanted there to be more meat for the
characters you know not just seeing us
for a quick moment and then it cuts away
and you have no real understanding
of who these characters are
or what the point of them is in this
space so i feel like we did a really
good job the writers did a really good
job of fleshing out these characters
fully
on screen and um
i feel like we did a really good job
portraying it as well the pussycats are
building a brand creating a signature
look okay we're telling a story not only
do we get the return of josie we got
valerie we got melody we got to find out
what they are up to and they're just
crushing life what was it like for you
to reunite with your bandmates and did
you ladies keep in touch over the years
it was great and we have kept in touch
you know it's hard when we're all so
spread apart but whenever somebody is
doing something like if haley's
releasing the music or asha with her new
ya novel you know i'll try to keep in
touch with them and and wish them well
and congratulations and you know
sporadic face time calls just to see
what's going on making sure everybody's
still alive
um you know
and it was also really fun to perform
with them again and i think you really
see that in the episode as well what do
you want to tease to the fans about the
episode a lot goes down it's by far my
favorite of the season so what do you
want to tantalize them with you're going
to see
sides of melody and valerie that you
have never seen
stories from them that you've never seen
yeah
and for josie
you're gonna see
her in totality you're gonna see her
struggle you're gonna see her just be
human in a way that
we haven't um and there will be no
cutaways okay
we are on screen
from start to finish read my glossed
lips
just in ginger like
not
gonna
happen i also love that we get pilot
josie sassiness the entire time
you know it's interesting because you
know i've been asked how did you prepare
for this episode you know this type of
josie
and there was time
that was just cozy it is it's who i've
always envisioned her to be
you know it there are spaces where i'd
like her to be softer and you see a bit
of that there are still moments that i
as like an actor i'm like oh my gosh i
remember i played there was a moment in
there where there was a color where she
was just a little bit less brown
but i definitely feel like you get to
see her
really just stepping into her own
you know and you see that with the other
girls too you know we really are we have
both feet on the ground we're really
strong in these characters and the
portrayal is there it also was a bit
easy for me to play josie at that point
because i myself am a budding young
adult and you know i have my own things
that i'm trying to overcome and face and
uh strengthen pieces of insecurities
that i carry with myself that josie has
as well